hallo herzlich willkommen zur tennis
welt viele von euch fragen mich immer
wie man eine torte mit ghanas glatt
streichen kann um sie später mit von
dort zu überziehen und heute zeige ich
euch das ganz kurz ich habe hier bereits
eine fertige torte ich habe sie schon
gefüllt und zwar ist es ein schock und
den habe ich mit gas gefüllt und die
rezepte findet ihr natürlich alle in
meinem blog und in meinem auch bei
youtube kanal und jetzt muss ich zuerst
einmal also die torte hat 26 zentimeter
im durchmesser und ich habe hier eine
tortenplatte 125 cm und jetzt muss ich
die torte am rand erstmal ein bisschen
kleiner schneiden als die platte unten
also wirklich rundherum so zwei
millimeter kleiner etwa und zwar hilft
mir das dann später dabei die torte
richtig schön auch am rand glatt zu
streichen
die restlichen kuchenstücke könnte immer
ganz gut so kickbox verarbeiten wenn ich
da einfach noch ein bisschen creme oder
zum beispiel ghanas dazu gibt beim film
der torte achte immer darauf dass ich
ganz oben mit der unterseite des
tortenboden abschließe dann hab ich
nämlich eine richtig schöne gerade
fläche jetzt kommt die erste schicht
kann nach drauf und die erste schicht
ist die krümel schicht die findet
nämlich alle kuchen krümmel und danach
muss die torte dann erstmal gekühlt
werden
und zuerst bestreite ich immer gerne die
oberfläche der torte und dann achte ich
auch immer darauf dass sich diese reste
nicht mehr in die andere schüssel mit
reihen gebe sondern der zweite schlüssel
habt dann kommen nämlich keine krümmel
mit in die garage und dann kommt die
seite dort heute drin
und die kleinen löcher die stopfe ich
immer ganz gerne und zwar geht es am
besten mit seiner kleinen winkel palette
dann ziehe ich immer die überreste so
ein bisschen mit einer tankkarte ab und
die erste schicht die muss jetzt auch
gar nicht perfekt sein die nicht
wirklich nur dazu dass die krümel
gebunden werden
jetzt stelle ich die torte für etwa 15
minuten in den kühlschrank und danach
kann ich sie glatt streichen
die erste schicht ist jetzt fest also
auch wenn man daran denkt klettern
nichts mehr dran
und jetzt kommt noch mal eine zweite
schicht ganz oben drauf und die wir dann
richtig glatt gestrichen und dann mache
ich es auch so ich streiche da immer
erst die oberfläche glatt und dann die
seiten und ich trage dafür immer ein
bisschen mehr cash auf und dann könnte
ich das immer schön wieder abziehen
und an den seiten ist es genauso als
eben ein bisschen mehr auftragen und
erziehe ich das alles gleich mit der
tankkarte ab
nach dem ersten abziehen sieht man hier
noch diese öffnungen wo überall noch
gespielt und da gehe ich dann immer mit
der kleinen winkel palette noch mal rein
stocksee aus und schießt dann noch mal
nachgehakt ab und ich finde es halt
immer ganz schön wenn torten hier unten
in den rechten winkel haben
deswegen setze ich die karte dann auch
immer so an dass ich es im rechten
winkel absetzen abziehen können
an der oberfläche schneide ich die
überreste immer gerne mit einem scharfen
messer
so bekommt man sie am besten weg
und dann muss ich jetzt hier noch die
unebenheiten glatt streichen und dann
ist die torte bereit für den von dauer
ich konsole die torte immer ganz gerne
noch mit einer wasserwaage die stelle
ich dann obendrauf
und wenn alles gut ist dann ist sie
perfekt und die torte ist jetzt bereit
um mit von dort überzogen zu werden ihr
könnt natürlich auch marzipan drüber
machen oder modelle schokolade wobei es
in der stadt immer etwas schwieriger
arbeitet als mit von dort die oberfläche
der torte ist jetzt sehr trocken das
heißt bevor ich sie dann mit von der
einkleidung sprühe ich nochmal etwas
back trend spray drauf dann haftet davon
drei immer ganz gut
ja ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
jetzt geholfen hat und dass ihr eure
taten jetzt auch immer alles schön glatt
gestrichen bekommt ich wünsche euch
schon mal ganz viel spaß dabei und wir
sehen uns das nächste mal wieder biss
dann tschüss